hey friends I'm Ilana and welcome to my
channel what today I am finally making a
video to celebrate hitting at 300,000
subscribers thank you guys so much I am
a little bit late to making this one
just because my health has been pretty
bad lately I don't think I made a new
video in two weeks I probably haven't
streamed in almost a month now but I do
my best and I did want to make sure that
I thank you guys anyway by giving you a
whole bunch of video games I have a ton
of games to give away I got as many
codes as I could get my hands on for you
guys just to say thank you for
supporting my channel for seven years so
today I'm making a video that I am
probably the most nervous about making
that I have ever been of any video I
have made on my channel I am going to go
back and watch old videos people have
been asking me to do this for a while
but I don't think people realize that
the first videos that I made on the
internet and not the ones on youtube.com
slash are Alana Zod know so for anyone
who doesn't already know that is one
video about it on my channel and I'm
sure I've spoken about it in a million q
and A's but I started making YouTube
videos because I wanted to learn how to
edit and I wanted to get more
comfortable on camera my second video
here is an interview with Josh Holmes
from three for three so I feel like you
can pretty easily tell that I was
already kind of doing the games media
thing before this channel existed
actually for like three years before
this channel existed so the first videos
that I have made on the Internet are
ones that you have probably never seen
before that are not on this channel and
I have not watched them since they went
up so that's where the nerves come from
so to start with a small synopsis I
started out working in games media by
volunteer writing so I found websites
that were advertising for volunteer
games writers there was one that I think
was called like video game journalism
jobs comm and I was writing as a
freelance
no not freelance it was literally as a
volunteer completely for free for about
a year before I started getting
freelance work that's a whole journey
but basically after awhile of writing I
had figured out that the industry games
media specifically was heading in the
direction of video content probably
because it's easier to sell ads on so I
was like hmm
this video thing you say I need to
figure out how to do that because I love
video games
and I like talking about them and I want
to make this my life and that'll make me
more employable sooo I started volunteer
video hosting which is probably pretty
much unheard of one of the first ones
that I did was a website that I was
already writing for so I just
transferred to hosting for them let's do
that one first it is called nonspecific
action see if we can even find the
channel I'm just assuming it's still
here
nonspecific there we go oh there she is
oh no I feel like this can't be good as
you can see July 2012 I think this is
literally the first video that I made
the first Alana piece hosted video okay
[Music]
my hair looks nice though look at me put
method into my appearance back in the
day I hate this this part I didn't write
that there is no way that I wrote that
that said I feel like I know exactly
what I was doing here I hate it I hate
how like it is that's terrible but I
feel like I was probably trying very
hard to be like apresenta to act like a
presenter and it took me a very long
time to learn that you can actually just
be yourself now I think with this
channel after that video I actually did
end up writing the scripts myself oh I
had changed nice
he can't respond to audios so bad I also
remember like when I was writing these
scripts seven years ago
why am I looking down so I know that
this was really difficult to film it was
on a really bad webcam I was using a
lamp for lighting and didn't have a mic
that not a webcam so I was a handycam so
I guess that handy cam has a better
audio than I would have thought but I
was looking at the notes on my phone and
then looking up like every sentence
that's why there have so many cuts it it
wasn't ideal and then I changed sets
feel like I was pretty proud of this one
that's good look I got candid very much
not to focus though and I remember yeah
being like it's a YouTube video I need
to be like a YouTube games boy and put
the things behind me which I mean was my
bedroom god I miss that he's had all
those I still have most of those
encyclopedias in Australia but ok so
this is the first outlet that I worked
for these are the first videos that I
ever made before any videos on my
personal channel and again I was doing
it because I wanted the experience cuz I
was like I need to work as a volunteer
before anyone will hire me for anything
actually because I just want to be in
games media this site I think I
mentioned was one that I found because I
was already writing for them as a
volunteer the next one I'm pretty sure
that the next ones that I worked for
basically like I just got my job by
hustling a lot I got to where I am today
by demanding that people let me make
stuff for them and the next one was it
was like I want to find one with a
bigger platform I want to find I'd
already done a little bit it's not good
but I was there and I wanted to host
with someone who had a slightly bigger
reach or a slightly bigger platform it
seemed like more of a challenge also
felt like it would give me some
legitimacy in the eyes of future
employers so I found this Facebook page
called videogame memes which is kind of
like trash community I'm sure if we look
at the comments you'll see that but I
messaged them and was like hey I want to
make a youtube show for you you can keep
all the ad revenue whatever I don't care
I think I just asked them to link my
profiles in the description and then we
would make a youtube channel for them
and I would make gaming news videos
every week and
and they would post those on that
Facebook page and see what happens so
that's the next one that I did again it
was my idea I just pitched it because I
wanted it to happen
that's that copyright there's no way
that's it
video game memes where are you these
channels are so small that they are hard
to find I think this is it okay yeah
that's me alrighty six years ago March
2013 I moved I don't know what that
faces this is my stepdads office hope
we'll have very bright good stuff
definitely wearing some more makeup
there also is to know about assassin's
creed black flag i still move my face
too much assassin's creed for edward
kenway
who is a privateer enlisted in the royal
this is still way too new zphone me it
how long did it take me to figure that
out
probably ages it probably took me making
my own channel to be like you don't have
to pretend to say everything like in
news anchor it does make me sound more
Australian when I do that there may be
some how come to piracy throughout the
wall I guess we made one video a month I
don't know maybe the comments are not
too bad uh well so yeah I kept making
videos here not for that long I guess
about a year maybe but these were all me
it's another setup change the camera
looks way better look at you upgrading I
liked this this fake say this was my
bedroom I think that has probably [ __ ]
be a game changer for the ps4 and it
certainly makes it a whole lot more
appealing to me any alien game I feel
like I chilled out a bit that took two
years of again volunteer making videos I
didn't realize that was volunteering for
the video for that long that's a long
time but then we go zelda news i started
also volunteering for Zelda universe so
this channel is mostly run by
Australians I think I did it because I
met the guy here
tiny little bridge promoting all the
news videos because I I'm selling you
Kel art is now accepting pre-orders for
the cards so for this one it's with
Zelda theme design I basically took
opening as it was on the site and then
rewrote it to be a script and you know I
knew which pots I would be reading and
then I would put the overlay over the
top so I was just in time his friend
it's a competition away in a latest
Super Smash Bros screenshot it's still
weird those I feel like there are other
places that I volunteered for but maybe
I don't remember the names but I feel
like they exist those are the ones I
remember and that was all before at some
points through here I was also working
for Xbox Australia I guess we could see
if we can find any of those videos but
they were paying me that wasn't
volunteer this is gonna be pretty old I
think and yeah that that obviously led
to me getting paid to host videos that's
me is that the first one this is the
first one I know that this interview is
bad I I was so nervous I think this was
the first time that I worked for Xbox
hey guys my name is Alana I'm the Xbox
insider here at IGN's Black Beta Phi
Halo 4
this is so wild oh man
yeah they flew me to Sydney this is so
nostalgic for me it's nuts
damn there's a cool event this is
wearing to be Josh I mean this video was
half on my channel xbox very politely
after that gave me makeup lessons they
paid for me to get makeup lessons and
pay for someone to do my hair because
they were like she looks like a [ __ ]
mess they didn't say that to me but the
next time that I worked for them I had
had like training on how to make myself
a look better because I just didn't
really know how to present on camera
yeah this is this is also cool as a
[ __ ] International Motor Show in
Sydney there was a I think of what's a
horizon competition here where you could
do this is so weird
that's me yeah these are all obviously
me as well
it's so nuts man it's just so weird it's
like six years doesn't seem like that
long but it seems like a lifetime so
weird okay so then aside from Xbox this
was my first paid job to get into the
business simple really
I just love games so yeah this was
button Bosch was like a TV show it's
very hard to actually explain what it
was but this is my first like
consistently paid video job where I was
fully writing the show they let me kind
of do whatever I want I could make
things super long but basically at it
was mostly short form videos that would
then be ported to TV networks or some of
the company stuff was on planes on other
websites it was like making small videos
that other people could sell ads on and
just kind of use his inventory if that
makes
and it was really fun because because of
the way that that model worked I really
could make pretty much whatever I wanted
we didn't have to worry about views on
here because the views on here didn't
mean anything yeah it was a lot of fun
14 to the designer on a new unannounced
project this whole thing was on this
like giant white green screen my first
time using a teleprompter so man if we
just just for fun jump to the first
video on my channel obviously you can
look at videos of me on fun house and on
roofs teeth and on IGN as well but this
is just like the origins of it all this
video right and when did you go up to
tropical totally 25th so I had been
volunteer making videos for a while and
I remember this one was because I wanted
to figure out how to capture gameplay it
looks like it's on a [ __ ] potato it's
true okay that is it for this video
yeah I just wanted to show some
background of how I started making
videos for people who probably have no
idea where my origins are it was not
this YouTube channel this just kind of
happened and I've enjoyed it so I've
stuck with it okay to get to giving you
guys codes my plan for the most part is
to just leave them in the comments I'll
just pin a comment and every day or hour
or whatever I'm gonna leave a new code I
do also have five deaths training codes
to give away Sony has specifically asked
me to make that a competition so if you
want a deaths training code for ps4
leave a place I can find you in the
comments below like if you want me to DM
you on Twitter or Instagram leave your
username or Facebook though people
usually miss it so I would advise
against Facebook and give me the name of
your des training character if diehard
man is character what is your death
stranding name what do you think you
would be called in desk rating the ones
that I find the most entertaining will
be the ones that I give coats do but
we've also got codes from Microsoft Xbox
obviously from private division from
Tarboro no PR from Claire Asiya
basically like a huge array of different
games thank you to everyone for
subscribing and sticking around I really
appreciate it I hope you enjoyed this
video
Oh yikes